news alert and that breaking news right
now an end out worker injured following
a construction incident in the east part
of the valley good evening to you thank
you for joining us at six i'm brian
loftus and i'm denise valdez so this
happened near stewart and eastern on a
bridge that was been in the state right
now of a controlled demolition
throughout the week sasha loft is live
on the scene with more details sasha
[Music]
denise and brian you can see there are
workers still out here right near where
this bridge demolition site is we are
told one ndot worker was hurt here in
what officials are calling a
construction incident that worker was
taken to the hospital no word yet on how
badly that person was hurt you can see
there is some caution tape up there and
it looks like there are some cars driven
people are kind of looking at that area
again no word on how badly that person
was hurt now the bridge again is being
demolished so road closures here on
eastern have already been in place for a
few days as for if this will impact the
construction schedule no word on that
yet not says it's too early to tell that
of course stay with eight news now for
updates on this this is a developing
situation again one n-dot worker hurt
here taken to the hospital no word on
how badly that person is hurt but for
now reporting live tonight sasha loftis
live local now